[Music]
Random Acts program 2 the pirate program
is titled the parable of the pardon the
king
I want to talk about the culture of
connection to God
we have
in our beloved family visuals require
risk I'm not a dumb assume says the
ritual is a spontaneous interaction
spirit and it can go all kinds of
different ways you don't know which way
it's going to go when you bring in
Spiritual Beings and that's what not
just dealing with that level of risk
risking reward with the process of
re-weaving with her mother who she was
raised to understand is her sister
we all have family secrets I think about
this a lot how it's just an extremely
different experience to be living a
family secret to be holding it in your
body to be the one that it's about and
to be even one degree outside of it it
can feel extremely but now like
why don't you just tell her you're like
whatever but to the person holding it
and the energy of it it's high stakes so
unfathomable story now to reveal oneself
is
life to death She's your sister
it's a girl
my baby girl my baby
[Music]